- It's a very simple
biscuit, and heads up,
biscuit is what you call a cookie here.
It's a pretty simple biscuit
(playful music)
These are Freddo Milk chocolates.
- What, look at the frogs!
- I know it was you
Freddo, you broke my heart.
(kisses wrapper)
- Freddo is not wearing pants.
- Yeah he's Donald Ducking it right now.
- Mine is just grabbing
his tummy and giggling.
- I decided to eat some
chocolate for pash!
I'm playing a guitar bitches!
(laughter)
It's a chocolate frog, but it's not
the chocolate frog from Harry Potter.
- If you have sensitive teeth like me,
this may not be the chocolate for you.
- Why?
- It's getting into the crevices.
- So we have the Violet Crumble here.
- Violet Crumble sounds like the name
of a love poem from the late 1700s.
- That frog chocolate
is still in my teeth.
- How the violet crumble,
when love shines not upon him.
- It's the way it shatters
that matters, which makes me
want to like--
(glass shatters)
- Cheers mate.
(crunching of chocolate)
Oh, hm
- Oh!
I like this texture, this is nice.
- It's like dehydrated ice cream.
- It's like a toasted marshmallow flavor.
- It sounds like a British nannies name.
(glass shatters)
(cat meows loudly)
- Cherry Ripe, let me guess,
- Your porn star name!
- Red juicy cherries and coconut
and old gold rich dark chocolate.
Is old gold, like a brand of chocolate?
- Oh!
- Woah!
- Not a pleasant interior, I must say.
- It looks a little bit like rice?
- This looks like a cough drop wrapper
- These are the chocolates my mom likes.
- This is some grandma
chocolate, I don't like this.
- Hey my mom's not that old.
- This smells like Valentine's Day.
- It looks like the
filling of an Almond Joy.
- I'm getting Thanksgiving
vibes from this.
- Yeah, cranberry sauce.
- That was the best one so far.
- You think so?
- Yeah.
- It's a very mature candy bar,
for mature people, for mature pallettes.
- I don't want maturity when
I'm eating candy, I want frivolity.
- Chokito!
Chokito.
Chewy caramel fudge, crunchy
balls, and loads of chocolate.
- Nothing I like better than balls
with loads, let me tell ya.
- That inside is a tunnel you
gotta start wasting some chocolate, yup.
- They made a candy bar,
and they're like wrapped
in another candy bar.
- It's my favorite one.
- It tastes like cereal.
Picnic, it's got a lot of nuts.
- This is the Chocito on steroids.
(chocolate crunches)
- Oh that's got a crunch to it.
- This is the Twix of Australia!
Chocolate and wafers,
it's very in your face.
- It's like those wafer candies
stuck into the middle of
a Snickers bar, and that's some shit!
- Tim Tams.
- Tim Tam.
- Wabam!
(crunch sounds)
- It's nice!
- Mmm!
- A chocolate biscuit.
- These are the ones that have
class and style, listen to the chew.
(crisp crunch)
- That was a very refined bite.
- Yeah.
- The Tim Tam that I think
are the best of the bunch.
- I like the frog because
it's just a simple bite
of chocolate in a really gnarly shape.
- You like the Cherry Ripe.
- Yeah, Cherry Ripe, best one we ate.
- Tim Tam.
- The one's that are kinda like cherry.
(laughter)
- There was just one that was cherry.
This is how you get ants by the way.
Call this video how to get ants.
(playful guitar music)